younes el fellah consultant en relations
internationales et spécialiste du monde
arabe
bonjour younes belhanda merci d'être
avec nous ce matin sur rtl france alors
le rapport américain a été rendue
publique vendredi soit deux ans et demi
après la mort de jamal racho guy quel
était l'intérêt de le déclassifiés
maintenant ce rapport bonjour moi je
crois qu'il ya des des remarques par
rapport à la publication de ce rapport
pour bien comprendre ou pour avoir des
éléments d'analysé soit sur le fond bien
sur la forme bien sûr l'opération déjà
mettre à jour j étais et exécuté en
octobre 2018 est bien évidemment
attendre jusqu'en février 2021 pour
donner ce genre de résultat je crois
qu'il ya vraiment un grand retard qui
était fait il y avait une volonté ses
skis tpiy avant par à l'administration
trempe de d'esclaves déclassifier ce
dossier alors que l'administration
baydan veut le divulguer je crois qu'il
ya manque là dessus parce que quand même
en parallèle d'un pays comme les etats
unis un pays de droit un pays et des
institutions donc normalement il fallait
par les services de renseignements de
publier ce rapport ou bien même que le
parlement fait un effort de publications
donc je crois que en fin de compte le
timing ou le temps politique qu'il
choisit pour la publication c'est un
temps qui était voulu par
l'administration byden afin de faire une
pression politique sur l'arabie saoudite
en même temps c'est un rapport là où on
trouve rien de nouveau à part la
responsabilité on va dire direct de du
prince héritier mohammed bin salman dont
il n'était pas encore précisé c'est à
dire cette question qui était citée sur
le rapport capturer ou bien tu es le
journaliste sont prendre en
considération également d'autres
rapports qui ont été faites sans par le
conseil des nations unies concernant les
le conseil des droits de l'homme des
nations unies ou bien d'autres rapports
qui a été fait soit par la turquie ou
bien même par par l'arabie l'arabie
saoudite
troisièmement en parlant de ceux de ce
rapport il faut prendre ont quand même
aussi en considération comme quoi c'est
un rapport qui vient quelques heures
après une conversation téléphonique
entre le roi salma aller entre le
président
by donne sur laquelle ils ont précisé où
ils ont confirmé l'importance accrue de
la de l'alliance stratégique contre
l'arabie saoudite et les etats unis donc
en fin de compte moi je crois qu'il
s'agit d'une pression politique
programmée par l'administration byden
sur le prince héritier mohammed bin
salman dont l'objectif par la suite ça
sera de politiser cette affaire
c'est-à-dire de politiser vraiment un
crime horrible inacceptable qui est le
nôtre de jamal khashoggi pour avoir des
intérêts géopolitiques et des intérêts
économiques par la suite yonath belle
fait là vous parlez de politiser cette
affaire par la suite
à travers ce rapport les états unis
accusent directement mois m ben salman
d'avoir joué un rôle dans l'assassinât
de de jamal khashoggi mais ne compte pas
sanctionné le dirigeant ça vous dire
pourquoi cette décision américaine
voilà ça montre un petit peu là on peut
dire l'hypocrisie américain concernant
cette affaire c'est à dire que même en
terme de sanction parce que les
américains savent parfaitement qu'il ya
une alliance stratégique qui a des
projets ont avec avec avec l'arabie
saoudite qu'ils ont besoin de l'arabie
saoudite pour le monde arabe pour les
pays du golfe ils ont besoin de l'arabie
saoudite pour les affaires du du pétrole
surtout que l'arabie saoudite c'est
parmi les premiers exportateurs du
pétrole dans dans le monde il ya eu une
alliance économique des investissements
des comptes bancaires et des comptes
d'investissement saoudien aux états unis
donc ce qui fait que en fin de compte on
est face à un geste politique qui veut
par la suite faire des changements dont
le comportement du prince héritier
mohammed bin salman
mais ça va pas changer la relation avec
avec avec les états unis
en même temps si on peut vraiment aller
loin dans cette dans cette analyse moi
je crois que pour l'arabie saoudite ce
genre de pression certainement ça peut
amener des changements en matière de
réformes juridiques ou même des réformes
en matière de droits de l'homme et de la
démocratie qui peuvent accompagner les
réformes qui ont été lancés en matière
de l'économie et du de la société à
parlons ici de la vision 2030 mais où
également ça peut vraiment changer la
donne de manière à l'arabie saoudite à
travers ce genre de pression
diversifier ses partenariats au niveau
international et ne peut pas compter
seulement sur les états unis en matière
d'armement ou bien en matière
d'investissement c'est à dire ça sera
vraiment une ouverture vers d'autres
puissances mondiales à l'égard de
l'union européenne la russie ou même
aussi la chine qui est un acteur
important et qui avance dans cette
région par pour ce qui concerne la
géopolitique je crois que avec le
contexte actuel il ya plein de dossiers
qui sont dans la région la sphère de
l'iran le liban la lutte contre le
terrorisme sont autant de dossiers qui
motive
en fin de compte une négociation
probable entre les états unis et
l'arabie saoudite et il faut aussi
préciser comme quoi c'est pas la
première fois que les etats-unis
appellent en fin de compte l'arabie
saoudite sur un dossier on se rappelle
bien en mai 2016 il y avait le rapport
de jasta qui était un camp ce concernant
la lutte contre le terrorisme et qui a
accusé en quelque sorte l'arabie
saoudite d'être derrière les événements
de 11,2 en septembre 2000 2001 mais en
fin de compte en matière on veut dire en
pratique ça n'a pas changé
l'important ça n'a pas changé le fond de
cette de cette relation du fait qu'il y
ait des intérêts réciproques mutuelle
entre l'arabie saoudite et les etats
unis merci beaucoup une asbl fait
d'avoir été avec nous ce matin sur rtl
france je rappelle que vous êtes
consultant en relations internationales
et spécialiste du monde arabe
merci beaucoup